avant de je sais pas si je pourrais
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
avez déjà posées madame la Présidente je
déclenche en même temps un compteur dans
votre propos introductif mais cela de
toute façon rejoint je pense les
réflexions que toutes celles et tous
ceux qui s'intéressent à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments des logements
se posent
j'en ajouterai d'ailleurs une ou deux à
mon tour je pense que sur ces politiques
là comme sur d'autres mais c'est
particulièrement vrai sur les sujets
écologiques il faut aussi se poser la
question de savoir si ce que l'on
recherche c'est ce qui est le plus
efficace et donc de déterminer aussi ce
qui est efficace le nombre de tonnes de
CO2 économiser chaque année l'énergie
économisée CO2 ou pas ou ce que l'on
recherche c'est ce qui est le plus
symbolique ou le plus efficace
médiatiquement ou politiquement ou dans
les débats politico
asiatique vous me permettrait de penser
que ce que l'on devrait rechercher c'est
ce qui est le plus efficace même si ce
n'est pas forcément ce qui est le plus
ce qui a le plus de succès médiatique ou
politique mais quand on est ministre
d'abord parler de mon expérience de
ministre on est sans cesse
confronté à
cette double entrée dans le débat si je
puis dire et je constate d'ailleurs en
étant resté un observer un observatoire
attentif même si j'ai pris un peu de
distance avec la responsabilité
politique nationale que ce double
questionnement n'a pas changé
permettrait même de penser que
malheureusement le plus symbolique
l'emporte largement et très souvent sur
le plus efficace il y a aussi une
question de fond récurrente également
est-ce que on recherche des politiques
plutôt incitatives ou est-ce que l'on
recherche ou en tout cas on accepte des
politiques plus contraignantes des
obligations légales réglementaires
est-ce que on accepte des contraintes
fiscales la question de la taxe carbone
qui était très très vive lorsque j'étais
ministre puisque vous en souvenez
c'était au moment où il y a le mouvement
des gilets jaunes mais il y a aussi d'un
point de vue fiscal des incitations
crédit d'impôts divers et variés j'y
reviendrai car ça a été un débat très
vif quand j'étais et du point de vue des
obligations réglementaires légales
législatif on voit bien que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est souvent difficile
à faire accepter notamment sur ces
sujets et on a eu des exemples très
concrets et puis il y a un troisième
questionnement un peu général qui je
crois tout le temps aussi toutes ces
politiques c'est est-ce que l'on croit
que l'efficacité vient d'une certaine
constance dans la politique monnaie dans
le temps ou est-ce qu'elle vient du fait
qu'on est capable de changer de se
remettre sans cesse en question et tant
de changer de dispositif ma conviction
est que il faut combiner l'incitation et
l'obligation l'incitation seule ne
marche pas ne suffit pas à atteindre des
objectifs importants l'obligation seule
évidemment rencontrent trop de
résistance chez les citoyens tout
simplement et on devrait privilégier
davantage de constance et on devrait
avoir davantage la mémoire de ce qui a
été fait ce qui a marché ou n'a pas
marché car j'ai constaté y compris quand
j'étais ministre que des choses que
j'avais vu passer dans un sens ou dans
l'autre lorsque j'étais député dont on
savait que telle ou telle chose marchait
plus ou moins de telle ou tel point de
vue ou marcher moins bien et bien on
continuait à vouloir essayer en quelque
sorte et à changer l'exemple plus
battant et les effets de balancier sur
les crédits d'impôts ça c'est
extrêmement clair il y a aussi un autre
une autre chose qu'il faut toujours
avoir en tête c'est que contrairement à
ce que croit je le dis d'autant plus que
c'est public et que c'est retransmis
est-ce que croit beaucoup de citoyens
une idée que propage aussi beaucoup de
responsables politiques malheureusement
et en tout cas de médias ça c'est sûr
les hommes et les femmes politiques qui
sont élus que ce soit le président de la
République ou plus haut niveau soit les
ministres qu'il a nommé et qui donc
sont en responsabilité en son nom ou les
députés d'une majorité cherchent à
mettre en oeuvre les promesses
électorales qu'ils ont faites et en ce
domaine il y en avait puisque vous en
souvenez en 2017 il y avait la promesse
de ne pas mettre enfin de sortir du
marché de la location les passoires
thermiques comme souvent les promesses
électorales ne sont pas définies très
clairement et très précisément d'un
point de vue technique ou sur les moyens
d'y parvenir et c'est évidemment
là-dessus que nous sommes heurté à
beaucoup de difficultés puis il y a
aussi une autre chose qui intervient
toujours qui est le contexte budgétaire
et donc tout cela évidemment sous tendu
mon action qui pourtant pour ce qui est
du gouvernement ne s'est déroulé que sur
10 mois alors sur pour être un peu plus
concret partir de cette partie là et je
veux bien répondre évidemment à des
questions sur ce qui a pu se passer
avant ou après déjà sous le premier
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron et où depuis ou
même avance ou d'autres mandats d'autres
présidents de la République d'autres
gouvernements
nous avons moi quand j'ai été nommé
ministre
j'ai été confronté tout de suite à un
sujet de négociation budgétaire puisque
j'ai été nommé tout début du mois de
septembre et donc le budget
le projet de loi de finances allait être
présentée dans les jours qui suivaient
par le gouvernement en conseil des
ministres puis au Parlement et il y
avait un débat à l'époque entre le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances son
ministre le ministre chargé des comptes
publics comme on dit et moi-même mais
mon prédécesseur avait également mené ce
débat sur ce qu'il devait advenir du
crédit d'impôt transition énergétique et
surtout de ce que l'on devait mettre
dedans donc un double débat sur le
volume
inutile de vous dire que les ministres
budgétaires on va les appeler ainsi
veuillez plutôt réduire le volume et
comme vous le savez dans ces cas-là
plutôt que de le dire aussi brutalement
on dit que l'on va resserrer les
critères que l'on va les resserrer
d'ailleurs d'un point de vue écologique
et d'un point de vue social ça j'ai
appris que les budgétaires savent bien
manier reprendre les arguments de ce
qu'ils ont en face de sur le fond pour
expliquer qu'ils font ça au nom de
l'écologie et de la solidarité que donc
il ne faudrait pas subventionner à
travers des crédits d'impôts des actions
même si elles sont pour de la rénovation
énergétique des logements si c'est des
gens qui auraient les moyens de le faire
sans cela donc ça c'est resserrer les
critères du point de vue des personnes
bénéficiaires et puis d'un point de vue
écologique de dire que alors on appelle
ça parfois les gestes je trouve ça un
peu bizarre c'est plus que des gestes
les travaux qui sont les moins efficaces
ne doivent plus être subventionnés et je
ne sais pas si vous en souvenez mais à
l'époque il y avait un gros débat sur
les fenêtres et donc quand j'étais mis
j'ai dû gérer si je peux vous dire la
crise des fenêtres puisque
il avait été déjà pas de fait négocier
avant que j'arrive que l'on sorte les
fenêtres des subventions possibles de
crédits d'impôt au motif que cela a été
le moins efficace du point de vue de la
baisse de la consommation d'énergie ou
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
là on sans être tout de suite dans le
symbolique ou l'efficacité de fait il y
a aussi un ressenti pour beaucoup de
gens le premier ressenti première chose
auquel il pense pour l'efficacité
énergétique c'est les fenêtres
d'ailleurs pour une raison simple mais
je trouve que c'était important de
savoir ce que les gens ont en tête quand
ils font un choix c'est que quand vous
approchez une fenêtre en simple vitrage
d'une fenêtre de dégradée ou de ancienne
et bien vous sentez le froid en hiver
tout simplement c'est aussi bête que ça
et donc vous dites si on met du double
vitrage on aura quelque chose qui sera
plus agréable et c'est ce ressenti et
puis par ailleurs c'est les travaux les
plus simples à faire et à commander et
évidemment les artisans du bâtiment et
leur fédérations ont fait une grosse
action pour expliquer que c'était la
pire des choses que de sortir les
fenêtres du crédit d'impôt moi j'ai
contribué à dire qu'en effet c'était un
peu brutal de les sortir puis au moins 5
ans et j'avais en mémoire
que lors de précédent mandat avec
d'autres gouvernements qui avaient déjà
essayé de faire des choses chaque fois
qu'on dit que on ne va subventionner
donc dans le cas d'une politique
incitative des travaux de rénovation
énergétique des logements si il n'y a
s'il y a d'un seul coup plusieurs types
de travaux ça me bouquet de travaux et
bien c'est plus efficace mais comme
c'est plus complexe on en fait moins et
il y a moins de gens comme on est
toujours dans l'incitation on n'est pas
dans l'obligation et il y a moins de nos
concitoyens qui sont prêts à se lancer
les budgétaires aiment bien ça puisque
évidemment ça permet de réduire la
dépense et ça ça s'est vu déjà sous des
précédents quinquennat à l'époque
c'était le crédit d'impôt développement
durable le CIDD et j'avais connu ça en
tant que député à l'époque j'ai des
membres de la commission des finances
pendant 5 ans j'ai vu ces choses là et
donc moi j'ai plaidais pour quelque
chose de d'équilibrer c'est-à-dire je
crois qu'il faut pas que ce soit trop
complexe si on met trop d'obligations
sur les bouquets de travaux et bien
évidemment on va avoir moins de gens et
il faut que ce soit accessible donc à la
fois type de travaux et en personne
assez largement
parce que si on dit qu'on va faire des
crédits d'impôts même si c'est des
crédits d'impôts c'est pas des
réductions d'impôts donc tout le monde
peut en bénéficier même ceux qui ne
payent pas d'impôts pour les gens qui
ont les plus faibles moyens qu'on dit on
le réserve à eux on a très peu de
travaux qui se font puisque les gens qui
sont prêts à se lancer dans les travaux
sur leur logement c'est en général les
gens qui sont déjà dans des tranches
fiscales plus élevées voilà alors après
on peut dire oui mais on va
subventionner des gens qui ont les
moyens oui mais est-ce que l'on veut
avoir des résultats ou pas voilà et
après c'est vrai que chaque année on
peut quand même ça c'est facile à
évaluer puisqu'on sait combien il y a eu
de chantier ces petits chantiers de
rénovation énergétique qui ont été faits
donc ça c'était un premier sujet lorsque
j'ai été nommé ministre tout de suite et
si vous voulez je pourrais revenir mais
ces deux là d'ailleurs qui est né l'idée
qu'il fallait réformer le système et
ensuite ça a donné lieu je n'étais plus
ministre mais j'y avais travaillé
j'avais préparé cela ma prime rénove et
donc un autre type de dispositif
d'ailleurs j'ai bien vu qu'après le
dispositif est à peine mis en place quoi
qu'on était déjà dans l'idée mais
prix de l'électricité je tiens quand
même à le rappeler de l'électricité donc
en France des carbonées mais c'était
moins de 50 euros le megawattheure comme
moi j'ai été nommé ministre même l'année
d'avance c'était moins le la reine était
à 40 euros n'était même pas
intéressantes pour les gens qui
achetaient de l'électricité en gros
donc un des moyens de donner une
perspective de dire toujours le sujet de
la constance dans la durée il faut
économiser l'énergie et il faut sortir
des énergies fossiles
c'était un outil
je pense et ça c'est malheureusement le
débat n'a plus lieu puis aujourd'hui il
est pas d'actualité parce que les prix
des énergies fossiles sont très élevés
mais si le remettent à baisser que on
aurait dû travailler plutôt que sur on
le fait on le fait pas on stoppe on
stoppe pas sur des mécanismes
d'adaptation aux réalités du marché bon
mais de garder cette perspective car
sinon évidemment on envoie un signal
général qui n'est pas bon pour les
économies d'énergie et la réduction des
énergies fossiles je le mets de côté
puisque ça a été tranché à l'époque et
depuis ça n'a pas bougé je crois
d'ailleurs quasiment aucun courant
politique ne propose de bouger sur le
sujet mais c'est dommage qu'il y ait en
France une sorte de tétanie ou de
traumatismes autour de cela parce que
évidemment c'est quand même un sujet de
fond au passage parenthèse mais qui a un
lien direct avec le logement j'ai vu le
résultat immédiatement sur les réseaux
de chaleur
des projets de réseau de chaleur qui se
faisaient au bois ils sont passés au gaz
parce que d'un seul coup ils étaient
beaucoup plus rentable façon de parler
moins coûteux avec du gaz qu'avec du
bois ah oui parce que la perspective
d'augmentation de la taxe carbone sur le
gaz faisait que ça valait le coup
d'aller sur du bois pour des
investissements qui s'amortit sur 20 25
ans
c'est quand même très concret tout cela
évidemment en terme de conséquence sur
l'efficacité énergétique et le climat
pour le logement nous avons eu aussi à
gérer donc la promesse faite par
Emmanuel Macron candidat à l'élection
présidentielle que j'avais soutenue donc
je me reconnaissais tout à fait dans son
programme qui était donc de sortie je
sais plus quel était la terminologie
j'ai longtemps gardé son programme mais
je ne l'ai pas avec moi mais
c'était écrit noir sur blanc de de
sortir de la location les passoires
thermiques quand on dit ça tout le monde
est d'accord bon dès qu'on commence à
rentrer dans la façon de faire là
évidemment on se heurte à les obstacles
qui pour ma part ne mettez pas inconnu
j'avais déjà connu sous un mandat
précédent avec une ministre du Logement
membre d'Europe Écologie Les Verts les
débats sur ce sujet et j'avais vu des
associations de solidarité
donc les pour la Fondation Abbé Pierre
ou ce type d'association dire attention
si vous faites ça vous allez sortir trop
de logements c'est des logements souvent
qui sont loués à très bas prix donc les
sortir du marché ça veut dire aussi
moins de logement bon mais à l'époque
nous avons un débat au sein du
gouvernement il y a pas tellement de
débats d'ailleurs à l'époque
sur le sujet ni au Parlement ni dans
l'opinion mais enfin bon il y a cette
promesse qui a été faite donc on voit
comment la mettre en œuvre le ministre
du Logement de l'époque
globalement si oppose je te suis claire
je sais pas si vous l'additionner mais
je pense que il ne contesterait pas ce
point donc on recherche d'autres
solutions
et dans la loi énergie climat dont vous
avez parlé qui a été adopté donc à
l'automne 2019 mais qui a été soumise en
première lecture au Parlement en juillet
enfin en juin 2019 et qui que j'avais
préparé en tant que ministre
je défends l'idée d'introduire une
mesure qui ne touchait pas le marché de
la location mais le marché de la vente
d'achat avant de logement et je propose
que l'on s'inspire de quelque chose qui
existe déjà dans le droit français
qui existe pour l'assainissement vous
savez sans doute lorsqu'un logement un
assainissement non collectif donc il
faut sceptique pour parler trivialement
qui n'est pas aux normes soit avant la
vente de sa maison parce qu'en général
c'est des maisons individuelles bien sûr
il doit faire les travaux soit une somme
est mise sous séquestre et c'est dans
l'acte notarié donc c'est totalement
transparent pour l'acheteur comme pour
le vendeur et évidemment l'acheteur doit
faire les travaux rapidement dans un
délai en général d'un an avec cette
somme
je j'ai été élu local à la communauté
urbaine de Nantes et la ville de Nantes
donc je connais parfaitement ce système
il a été mis en oeuvre d'ailleurs à
l'époque où j'étais élu donc ça
fonctionne ça a permis de traiter c'est
le cas de le dire tous les
assainissements qui n'étaient pas au
nord donc je propose que l'on fasse un
système de même type pour les passoires
thermiques alors les logements
individuels parce que sur les logements
collectifs ça serait pas possible
lorsqu'il y a des ventes
je finis par obtenir des arbitrages
favorables du Premier ministre mais je
crois que le ministre du Logement n'y
était pas favorable non plus et je vois
fleurir à l'Assemblée nationale en
commission des amendements y compris de
députés de la majorité qui s'y opposent
et donc nous avons de nouvelles
discussions et finalement cette idée est
abandonnée
personnellement je le regrette non pas
parce que c'était
j'avais la paternité de cette idée mais
parce que je crois que traiter cette
question à travers le marché moi je suis
pas contre l'économie de marché bien au
contraire je pense simplement qu'il faut
l'orienter par les règles que nous que
vous votez au Parlement et donc c'est
une façon de gérer dans le marché vous
dites pas à partir de telle date ah oui
bah chaque fois qu'il y a une vente et
un achat mais il y aura une mise aux
normes alors il fallait voir jusqu'où
sur parce que c'est vrai qu'évidemment
sur des logements ça on avait sorti
d'ailleurs à l'époque je les ai pas de
mémoire mais des statistiques très
précises sur quel combien de logements
et donc de personnes derrière étaient
concernés par exemple de mémoire 500
maison individuelle donc passoire
thermique donc je pense que ça devait
être FG qui était
dans les personnes propriétaires
occupantes
oui parce que dans ces cas-là on agite
les peurs mais il faut bien et donc on
pouvait dire bah voilà on peut aussi
évidemment accompagner aider ses 500 000
foyers sachant qu'on ne le fait pas du
jour au lendemain puisque c'est au fur
et à mesure des achats ventes
je ne sais pas si cette idée reviendra
jour mais je la livre à votre réflexion
n'a pas été elle n'a pas fait Flores
depuis
et il faut le dire la promesse sur la
location a été mise en œuvre d'une
certaine façon lors de la loi climat
résilience elle avait été relancé
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire par la
Convention énergie enfin convention des
citoyens sur le climat et ça me permet
de d'ailleurs de d'en dire un mot
cette convention nous l'avons lancé
croit pouvoir dire en être un des
en revendiquer une partie de la
paternité et nous n'étions pas très
nombreux je dois dire au sein du
gouvernement Hayette favorable je crois
que même en dehors du président de la
République et de moi-même au sein je
veux dire du de l'exécutif il y avait
personne à la défendre beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs essayé de la tort elle a été
faite et une des missions était celle là
c'était écrit noir sur blanc dans la la
lettre de mission si on peut dire
c'est-à-dire rechercher des solutions
acceptables par les citoyens parce qu'on
voit bien qu'à chaque fois on bute sur
des questions d'acceptabilité que ce
soit pour le marché de la location ou
que ce soit pour le marché de l'achat à
vendre des logements
acceptable pour les citoyens sur cette
question donc de l'impact climat et on
peut dire énergétique aussi des
logements et donc le sujet de la
rénovation et je vois d'ailleurs
que nous l'avons voté non sans débat
d'ailleurs je dis nous parce que là
j'étais député à cette époque là donc je
l'ai soutenu
et qu'évidemment ce qui avait été dit ce
produit en partie c'est à dire c'est un
peu tôt pour le dire mais un certain
nombre de logements sont retirés du
marché de la location
bon on me dit aussi les professionnels
de l'immobilier disent que on les
retrouve sur le marché des ventes
d'ailleurs donc preuve que c'est
peut-être un mouvement par le biais du
marché qui est en train de se faire
parce qu'évidemment ceux qui vont devoir
les ventes pour les relouer ils vont
devoir et faire des travaux donc
évidemment à suivre dans l'évaluation et
moi je souhaite d'ailleurs que on fasse
une évaluation avant de changer quoi que
ce soit parce que si on fait des
changements avant d'avoir évalué on
risque pas d'avoir mesuré l'efficacité
ou les effets pervers qui peuvent
exister naturellement donc la convention
citoyenne sur le climat je pense que sur
le sujet c'est principalement ça
contribution des remarques plus générale
je pourrais emporter je cache pas que
moi j'ai été un peu déçu par les
résultats alors que j'ai porté cette
idée mais voilà sur le sujet qui vous je
crois que c'était ça la chose voilà je
crois ce que je pouvais dire en
propos général déjà assez long et sur le
fait que
je crois que on a aussi une marque plus
générale sur le financement parce que
vous l'avez évoqué madame la Présidente
aujourd'hui depuis quelques années
d'ailleurs on ne manque pas de
financement privé sur le sujet on se
focalise beaucoup sur le financement
public à travers les crédits d'impôts à
travers les subventions etc
oui mais enfin il faut quand même
d'abord et avant tout le logement c'est
d'abord une question de mobilisation de
l'argent privé
à part le logement social qui fait appel
pour une part de l'argent public mais ce
qui sinon s'autofinance d'ailleurs il
faut rechercher la mobilisation soit de
l'épargne individuelle soit du crédit
bancaire nous vivons depuis quelques
années avec des taux d'intérêt très bas
cette période semble se terminer
néanmoins les taux d'intérêt restent
très inférieurs en réalité à l'inflation
donc il reste quand même
assez bas par rapport à d'autres
périodes que nous avons connues il y a
pas si longtemps donc ça c'est une
première source et je pense que les
tiers financement c'est à regarder
peut-être plus sur la des bâtiments
collectifs que sur de l'habitat
individuel sont aussi à mobiliser bien
sûr il y aura toujours une part d'argent
public mais c'est pas dans l'inflation
d'argent public que l'on résoudra le
problème et il y aura toujours une part
pour moi d'obligation légale
réglementaires et c'est toujours la
combinaison de ces différents moyens en
essayant d'agir dans la durée qui à mon
sens permettra d'obtenir des résultats
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
merci merci Madame ma présidente
monsieur le monsieur le ministre déjà
pour ces explications à la fois larges
et précise en tout cas sur des sur des
exemples très pessimistes je pense et
qui peuvent vraiment faire avancer nos
travaux peut-être quelques quelques
précisions parce que vous avez déjà
répondu à beaucoup de choses c'est vrai
que ça a été dit donc vous avez été en
charge du texte sur NRJ et climat donc
en 2019
c'est vrai que dans ce texte il y avait
déjà des éléments assez précis vous avez
un petit peu expliqué les différents
arbitrages je dirais perdu ou gagner
mais en tout cas les orientations qui
avaient été qui avaient été fait et les
questionnements dont on se pose toujours
sur effectivement comment on s'attaque
justement à cette question des passoires
thermiques et par quel dispositif et
justement est-ce qu'on a un mécanisme
plutôt coercitif ou plutôt
d'accompagnement ou les deux mais en
tout cas
non c'était peut-être de voir dans les
différents dispositifs traverse ce texte
qui déjà voilà avait des ambitions assez
fortes peut-être les éléments sur lequel
peut-être vous regrets en tout cas sur
lequel alors vous en avez un petit peu
parlé sur notamment ce mécanisme sur la
vente qui effectivement peut-être
peut-être intéressant mais est-ce que
vous avez voilà sur les arbitrages je
dirais perdus en tout cas sur les
orientations
de vous dire maintenant au regard de ce
qui a été fait et puis peut-être au
regard aussi
du texte de la loi climat sur lequel
pour le coup ça a été tranché et
notamment l'interdiction à des des
logements 1er janvier 2023 afin de la
location pour les passoires thermiques
ben voilà le regard que vous pouvez
avoir et effectivement ben là on verra
un petit peu le bilan de ce qu'il en est
mais peut-être des éléments en tout cas
qui vous auraient peut-être permis
d'aller peut-être plus vite et peut-être
plus loin sur cette sur cette première
phase ensuite peut-être une question sur
l'aspect sur l'aspect budgétaire vous en
avez aussi beaucoup parlé c'est vrai que
souvent sur la question de la rénovation
thermique forcément c'est qu'il faut de
l'argent public privé mais en tout cas
il faut il faut de l'argent et ça
nécessite beaucoup d'argent mais on voit
aussi et c'est vrai que si on regarde
les différentes politiques publiques qui
ont été menées qui ont souvent été avec
beaucoup d'ambition et quel que soit je
dirais les ministres et les différents
gouvernements
souvent quand même avec des budgets
alors toujours se dire que c'est plus
c'est que mais souvent se pose la
question d'efficacité en fait de
l'efficacité de cette de cet argent là
où il est mis et des résultats qu'on
peut obtenir derrière avec avec l'argent
mis en place voilà est-ce que ça a fait
partie des questionnements que vous avez
pu vous avez pu avoir et notamment à
travers les arbitrages qui ont été faits
et clairement est-ce que vous pensez que
si on avait mis beaucoup plus d'argent
est-ce qu'on serait allé beaucoup plus
vite et beaucoup plus loin
notamment après se pose la question de
la réalisation et de la possibilité qu'à
travers les à travers les entreprises
avec les capacité qu'on peut avoir sur
les questions des matériaux etc mais
est-ce que vous pensez en tout cas
est-ce que ça a été un frein dans dans
l'application de vos politiques de vous
dire voilà si on avait pas doublé le
budget est-ce qu'on serait allé deux
fois plus vite quoi je pense que ça
c'est voilà c'est ça ça m'intéresserait
d'avoir votre tour et puis peut-être
donc vous avez parlé du crédit d'impôt
du cice qui a été transformé ensuite en
prime rénov d'avoir peut-être puisque
voilà d'avoir les deux les deux aspects
et de voir un petit peu ce que vous
pensez par rapport à cette modification
et puis peut-être à travers ça moi c'est
peut-être un sentiment que j'ai sur
l'évolution de ces différentes
politiques publiques et de ce qu'on peut
faire c'est que c'est souvent un peu un
empilage et qu'on a un peu du mal
souvent à faire un peu un bilan et c'est
un peu le but justement de cette
commission d'enquête de ce qui a été mis
en place de l'efficacité ou non et quand
on vient rajouter à chaque fois un petit
peu une couche et du coup on arrive à
quelque chose qui est qui est parfois un
petit peu éligible donc ça
m'intéresserait d'avoir peut-être votre
votre avis en tout cas sur ce sur cet
aspect là
et sur voilà le dispositif prime rénov
ma prime rénov aujourd'hui savoir si
c'est vrai que les dernières
les derniers rapports qu'on a pu qu'on a
pu avoir et on s'aperçoit quand même que
même s'il y a eu à la fois la fonctionné
il y a eu pas mal d'argent dépensé on
s'aperçoit qu'on reste quand même sur
des gestes encore très très simple vous
avez parlé des fenêtres mais voilà mais
ça peut être les chaudières aussi et
qu'on se retrouve quand même sur des
éléments très
très faible en termes en termes
d'intervention voilà globalement et puis
peut-être pour laisser quand même la
place à mes collègues sur votre
peut-être votre vision sur
l'appréciation et l'évolution de la
politique de rénovation énergétique
c'est à dire que
sur sur les perspectives et les
orientations qui peuvent être données et
sur ce qui peut être mis en place avoir
un petit peu votre votre sentiment par
rapport à par rapport à ça
c'est vrai que notamment on a pu avoir
quelques interventions le fait que de
dire que
on obtenait peut-être pas forcément
toujours les résultats qu'on aurait pu
penser quoi voilà et donc peut-être
avoir aussi cette vision merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors d'abord moi
je pense qu'en matière d'écologie c'est
particulièrement vrai sur le logement il
faut viser des changements profonds
c'est pas c'est sûr que ça peut pas être
juste des des petits changements qui
vont régler le problème des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre si on prend ce
problème là qui est le problème majeur
qui ne l'oublions pas grosso modo
logement tertiaire en France c'est à peu
près un tiers des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc c'est quand même un
des sujets majeurs avec les transports
et moi je crois depuis toujours
que c'est des changements pour qu'il
soit profond il faut qu'il soit durable
mais pour qu'il soit durable il faut
qu'il soit progressif moi je ne crois
pas au changement brutaux c'est à dire
d'un seul coup on va
imposer une règle qui va tout changer ça
je et alors c'est particulièrement vrai
dans le domaine du logement parce que
dans le domaine du logement on touche à
une des choses essentielles pour les
Français
que les gens d'ailleurs en soi
propriétaire ou locataires mais c'est
encore plus vrai quand ils en sont
propriétaires et ont tout on se heurte à
quelque chose on voit d'ailleurs que si
on intègre pas ça dans la réflexion
on aura toujours du mal à penser des
choses efficaces on se heurte à quelque
chose qui est que dans la tête de
beaucoup de propriétaires qui occupent
leur logement
encore aujourd'hui il est tout à fait
logique
d'investir de l'argent pour faire ce
qu'on appelle une rénovation mais une
rénovation on va dire d'agrément mais
c'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est
tout à fait bien de se sentir bien dans
son logement donc on change les
peintures les sols la cuisine la salle
de bain on investit facilement des
sommes importantes quelqu'un qui achète
d'ailleurs une maison et si vous en avez
fait le test vous avez sans doute
vérifier d'ailleurs les agents
immobiliers
de travaux voilà il y a 50000 euros de
travaux et ça paraît pas du tout
choquant et on fait un budget et puis
voilà et on a jamais réussi à avoir le
même raisonnement sur l'efficacité
énergétique
et y compris des gens qui sont sensibles
à gazon ils ont moins ce raisonnement là
il ne raisonne pas en termes d'agrément
autour alors que un logement bien isolé
est un logement plus agréable à vivre
mais c'est comme ça donc il faut
d'ailleurs il faudrait travailler
là-dessus il y a un autre élément par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit moi je
crois qu'il faut dire les choses
clairement en France on aime bien les
crédits d'impôts
particulièrement sur le logement je
parle des citoyens
et j'ai aussi suivi les politiques du
logement pendant plus de 10 ans dans les
deux premiers mandats députés dès que
vous avez resserré l'accès au crédit
d'impôt pour l'investissement locatif ça
c'est sinon effondré en tout cas ça a
fortement baissé c'est comme ça et donc
on peut dire c'est pas bien c'est bien
là les budgétaires de Bercy il déteste
les crédits d'impôts puisqu'il
évidemment c'est une dépense en plus qui
n'est pas limitée c'est un droit donc
évidemment une fois que c'est parti il
faut payer mais c'est efficace c'est à
dire que ça déclenche parce que les
Français n'aiment pas les impôts tout
simplement mais notamment l'impôt sur le
revenu mais bon ça c'est un autre débat
et je les comprends d'ailleurs mais ça
c'est une appréciation personnelle autre
problème c'est qui fait
on voit bien qu'on se heurte alors c'est
plus vrai sur le logement individuel
mais ça peut parfois être vrai sur des
copropriétés privées enfin c'est vrai
aussi sur les copropriétés privées à qui
va déjà la première impulsion faire un
audit énergétique même pas la peine de
dépenser des sons mais quand même un
audit énergétique pas simplement un DP
pas simplement un diagnostic de
performance énergétique qu'est-ce qui
cloche sur mon logement qu'est-ce qui
serait prioritaire qu'est-ce qui serait
le plus efficace ainsi de suite bon
c'est difficile d'imposer de dire si
vous voulez avoir un crédit d'impôt faut
d'abord avoir fait ça mais ce serait
quand même un sujet de réflexion mais si
on disait ça qui fait
alors sans doute certains s'en
souviennent à une époque ça a l'air
d'être moins d'ailleurs à la mode
aujourd'hui mais il faut bien le dire
des majorités de gauche j'en ai fait
partie donc c'est pas du tout
une critique mais ont beaucoup phosphoré
sur le service public de l'efficacité
énergétique
sp2e ça a du même être mis dans une loi
bon
moi je l'ai jamais cru ça je vous le dis
tout de suite parce que je crois pas que
son multipliant les services publics
divers et variés que sur un sujet qui
est aussi différent d'un Français à
l'autre d'une région à l'autre etc que
ça va être efficace puis il faudrait
recruter des des dizaines de milliers de
personnes partout sur les territoires
pour faire moi j'ai été regardé quand
j'étais ministre des expériences très
concrètes je me souviens d'une
communauté de communes qui avait fait
quelque chose de très bien mais elle
traitait sans logement parlant une
communauté de communes de plus de 50 000
habitants pas une petite communauté de
communes donc c'est elle avait elle-même
évalué que sur son territoire si on
faisait ça il y en avait pour 100 ans
j'exagère peut-être un peu mais à peine
donc moi j'avais plaidé mais je n'ai pas
été suivi je dois le dire quand j'ai été
ministre pour une solution qui a aux
yeux de certains apparaisseraient
peut-être comme libéral une je l'assume
totalement de faire appel à des
opérateurs privés c'est-à-dire de dire
voilà on dit on lance on l'appelle Love
on fait des lots parce que c'est 50 000
logements parce que c'est 100000
logements puisqu'on dit qu'on veut en
faire 500000 par an c'est souvent été
l'objectif 100
000 et c'est des gens ils seront
rémunérés sur le résultat résultat en
émission de gaz à effet de serre
économiser et en performance énergétique
et eux ils vont s'occuper de faire
l'audit énergétique de conseiller les
gens en travaux éventuellement ils vont
s'occuper d'ailleurs de faire les
travaux pour le compte du propriétaire
et c'est eux qui géreront également les
subventions ça existe
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai inventé
dans ma petite tête on le fait pour on
l'a fait pour certains qui ont bénéficié
à l'époque c'était un euro la chaudière
ou autre il y a une société je préfère
de publicité il y en a d'autres qui
s'appelle les filles qui fait ça alors
on m'a dit NON NON même dans un
gouvernement comme celui de Monsieur
Macron mais non non non ouh là là on va
pas faire appel à des privés on va
confier ça à la nappe l'Agence Nationale
pour l'Amélioration de l'Habitat
je change jamais je la connais la nage
les pratiquais quand j'étais élu local
très bien elle sait très bien faire sur
les copropriétés dégradées quelque chose
de très très approfondi très subtil mais
en très petit nombre et ça n'a pas raté
d'ailleurs on a augmenté les crédits
pour Lana mais ça n'a pas suivi en
réalisation
bon là aussi je ne dis pas que c'est une
recette miracle mais je pense qu'on
devrait quand même creuser cela et
dernier point vous avez évoqué et ça
c'est vrai que j'ai oublié d'en parler
alors que ça a été un élément majeur là
qui jouait à fond sur la symbolique
quand j'étais ministre
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
le Premier ministre c'est pas moi qui
m'exprime c'est le premier ministre
Édouard Philippe dit un jour dans une
interview à la radio dans une matinale
voilà nous envisageons de sortir du
fioul de sortir des chaudières au fioul
dans les logements individuels à
l'époque je pense que les chiffres n'ont
pas tellement changé 3 millions de
logements individuels chauffés au fioul
sans compter d'ailleurs les chaufferies
collectives au fioul y compris dans des
bâtiments publics y compris dans des
mairies qui se disent très à la pointe
sur le sujet et donc on dit ça et on dit
d'ailleurs c'est une image c'est 3
millions de petites centrales thermiques
on veut supprimer les centrales
thermiques tout le monde est d'accord
là-dessus on peut le faire les logements
les solutions existent
pompe à chaleur le gaz là où il y a du
gaz eau de performance meilleur
rendement ou le bois
et là surprise vous pourriez le 21 juin
si vous avez le temps mais il a été un
peu traumatisé par cet épisode tous les
général comment on veut nous interdire
c'était sortir avec été réinterprété
comme interdiction en gros ce qu'on
disait ça ne peut plus en réinstaller et
bien on va aller on va parler arracher
une chaudière au fioul chez quelqu'un en
disant maintenant obligé de la remplacer
par autre chose et bien ça ça a été
intolé y compris au sein du gouvernement
c'est un m'ont expliqué que leurs
parents étaient très attachés
aujourd'hui donc on a
on a stoppé net on s'est revenu après
mais je vois bien d'ailleurs que c'est
pas parce que ça revient que c'est réglé
mais quand même heureusement parce que
ce sont des actes concrets et là il y a
pas besoin de faire un audit énergétique
très puissant il y a au moins lorsque
les chaudières tombent pas moi je dis
pas forcément des chaudières qu'on
disant les mets à la poubelle et on en
place mais
chaudière elles arrivent en fin de vie
au moment les remplacement c'est plus
possible mais à l'époque simplement ça
alors en plus c'était à l'époque
l'argument qui emporte et tout vous
allez remettre des gilets jaunes sur les
ronds-points voilà le mouvement de
défense des chaudières au fioul après
tout ça ne se fait pas en un jour c'est
pas toujours facile mais expliquer comme
je l'ai entendu à l'époque qu'il y avait
des gens pour qu'il y avait pas de
solution
c'est pas vrai solution technique
existent oui une pompe à chaleur c'est
plus cher oui une chaudière à gaze haute
performance c'est plus cher oui il y a
pas du gaz partout mais il y a quand
même de l'électricité partout dans notre
pays et il y a le bois qui est une
ressource en plus qui peut être
française et bien ça à l'époque ça n'a
pas ça c'était un regret que nous
n'ayons pas pu avancer plus vite encore
une fois il s'agissait pas d'interdire
du jour au lendemain etc c'est toujours
des choses qu'on fait progressivement
mais qui sont ensuite des changements
durables et utiles
vous sur cette importance sujet
que la rénovation et la performance
énergétique des bâtiments
c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours
passionné qui m'a toujours mobilisé et
quand la première chose parce que vous
avez l'expérience du des actions locales
et quand je suis arrivé dans ce
ministère et j'avais déjà tenté avec
parfois avec succès d'ailleurs je le dis
modestement à faire de ma région la
région de l'excellence environnementale
et une des premières décisions que j'ai
prise en 2004 en arrivant c'est de
construire le premier lycée c'est un
lycée professionnel à côté de Poitiers
le premier lycée a énergie positive
d'ailleurs appelé lycée Kyoto alors tout
le monde s'est étonné pourquoi on est en
poids tout qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
le Japon vient faire là et comme je
pense que toutes les opportunités sont
bonnes à prendre pour apprendre des
choses j'avais expliqué donc c'était le
nom du premier protocole climat le
protocole de Kyoto
donc ce lycée a été construit à la fois
avec les énergies renouvelables
récupération d'eau de pluie performance
énergétique isolation etc et quand je
suis donc arrivé
dans ce ministère avec cette
responsabilité là je vais déjà
développer et vu un certain nombre de
choses sur la fois les opportunités
opérationnelles et sur les freins aussi
à la rénovation énergétique en
particulier sur le logement social je me
souviens
ça doit être pareil sur vos territoires
à l'époque quand il y avait des
logements sociaux ont supprimé les
cheminées dans le milieu rural et moi
qui venais qui est passé ma vie dans mon
enfance en milieu rural dans les Vosges
on se chauffe au bois les chambres
étaient pas chauffées donc on apprenait
les économies d'énergie ça paraît
relever du siècle dernier mais c'est
vrai que du coup j'avais dit mais non
sociaux mais non vous laissez les vous
laissez les les cheminées alors on me
dit maintenant les gens vont déclencher
les vont déclencher les feux de cheminée
je lui dis non on est en milieu rural
les gens savent parfaitement se chauffer
au bois ça fait des générations qu'on le
fait et donc ça m'a fait plaisir après
en revenant au ministère de relancer la
filière bois de chauffage et la
cogénération au parce que c'est vraiment
des filières formidables en France on a
un potentiel
forestier très très important ça c'est
pour vous donner un petit peu le
l'ambiance et ensuite donc j'ai fait
voter la loi de transition énergétique
que j'ai voulu exemplaire avant la COP
21 ce que l'idée de se dépêcher pour la
loi de transition énergétique de du mois
d'août 2015 c'était dire bon bah la
France accueille la COP 21 il faut
vraiment qu'on soit exemplaire et qu'on
anticipe les contraintes de la COP 21
dans notre propre stratégie nationale et
dans notre stratégie bas carbone donc
peut-être en deux mots pour voir comment
est-ce que le titre sur les bâtiments
s'insèrent dans cette loi il y avait
trois objectifs que j'avais à signal à
la loi de sur la croissance verte
c'était bien sûr contre le réchauffement
climatique c'était ensuite réduire la
facture énergétique qui est de 70
milliards de déficits de la balance
commerciale à ce moment-là et c'était
développé des filières de compétitivité
et d'innovation dans ce domaine avec
deux outils opérationnel parce que j'ai
toujours pensé que le local le Global
c'est à dire l'international comme 21 le
National les stratégies nationales et le
local les territoires et les citoyens
doivent tous tirer dans la même
direction si on veut des résultats et
dans cette loi donc j'ai créé les
territoires énergétiques avec en
particulier parce que c'était la
première préoccupation des élus c'est
l'isolation des bâtiments municipaux en
particulier pour faire des économies
d'énergie d'une part et puis le crédit
d'impôt de transition énergétique qui
permettait aux particuliers sans
condition de ressources puisque
j'estimais qu'on était dans une
transition énergétique et que il fallait
permettre à tout le monde de se remettre
à niveau sur l'isolation des logements
le crédit d'impôt donc je dis bien le
crédit d'impôt c'est à dire que les gens
qui n'étaient pas imposables avaient
donc ce crédit qu'il aurait été apporté
pour pouvoir faire des travaux parce
qu'on disait quand on vous dit il y a
pas de conditions de revenus non et donc
ceux qui payent pas d'impôt ben n'en
bénéficie pas non c'était pas une
déduction fiscale c'est un crédit
d'impôt donc il recevait le versement de
l'équivalent de de l'investissement donc
c'était 8000 euros par personne seul et
15000 euros pour un couple 16000 euros
pour un couple de déduction fiscale
davantage fisc davantage fiscal pour les
travaux de d'énergie
d'efficacité énergétique
et Madame là Président vous avez raison
de dire que la performance énergétique
ça concerne les bâties les bâtiments ils
avaient dit les deux tiers c'était avant
les transports on l'oublie parce que le
transport on voit l'essence mais non
c'est bien le bâtiment qui consomme le
plus d'énergie avant les transports et
même avant l'industrie donc c'est
considérable en fait donc le potentiel
il est considérable et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette filière c'est
comme je viens de le dire c'est qu'il y
a la fois des décisions individuelles
des décisions municipales des décisions
départementales des décisions régionales
des décisions nationales des décisions
de l'industrie aussi parce qu'il y a des
bâtiments industriels il y a des
bâtiments commerciaux il y a des
aéroports qui devraient toutes
uniquement il devrait y avoir déjà des
centrales solaires sur tous les
aéroports français s'emparer de la
récupération d'eau de pluie qui pourrait
laver les avions au lieu d'utiliser
l'eau potable enfin bon c'est pour ça il
est quand même un peu trop lent mais
tout ça avait été dit pendant les débats
de et ça c'est vraiment consensuel parce
que tout le monde quel que soit le voyez
les partis politiques les groupes
politiques ça c'est vraiment des sujets
je me souviens dans la loi de transition
énergétique qui ont passionné tout le
monde est vraiment les les votes étaient
acquis à l'unanimité
donc ensuite
l'autre objectif de la loi c'était ne
pas opposer les énergies les unes aux
autres donc je passe sur la polémique
sur l'énergie nucléaire parce que ça
concerne pas le bâtiment et puis surtout
donc les faire des énergies propres des
énergies sûr et des énergies les moins
chères possible donc c'est dans ce
cadre-là finalement que
se situe la problématique d'économie
d'énergie de performance énergétique et
le grand chantier du bâtiment qui permet
de faire baisser les factures pour les
gens de créer des emplois dans le
bâtiment
d'économiser l'énergie au niveau
national
il y a que du c'est que du plus c'est
que du positif c'est que du
gagnant-gagnant pour tout le monde donc
vous avez bien déjà commencé à détailler
tous les outils que j'avais mis dans la
loi d'abord premièrement des nouvelles
règles qui rendent des marchés et
réduisant les coûts donc avec les
bâtiments énergies positifs et afin
faibles empreinte carbone et mon idée
alors c'est trop audacieux donc c'était
dire tous les nouveaux bâtiments vous
devrez être bâtiment énergie positive ça
me semblait tellement évident moi
j'avais vu que c'était possible j'en
avais fait mais la filière du bâtiment
résistait quand même beaucoup et j'ai
pas compris pourquoi parce que je les
faisais venir finir du bâtiment j'y mets
c'est votre intérêt vous allez créer des
emplois des activités mais il y avait
quand même une grande inertie et
d'ailleurs ils ont fait supprimer le
l'individualisation des frais de
chauffage ils ont fait supprimer plein
de choses et il y avait la pression du
bâtiment et je leur ai expliqué mais
c'est dans votre intérêt puisque vous
allez pouvoir développer même des
savoir-faire des nouveaux matériaux
faire des économies même dans la
construction conquérir des marchés
international si on est les meilleurs
sur ce secteur vous allez vous déployer
vous développer etc il y avait quand
même beaucoup de réticences
et moi mon idéal pour répondre à la
question que vous avez posé qu'est-ce
que je regrette c'est que tous les
nouveaux bâtiments il est pas trop tard
soit tous à énergie positive qu'est-ce
que c'est un bâtiment énergie positif
même moi j'avais donné au territoire et
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont déjà
construits notamment des logements c'est
un bâtiment qui produit au moins autant
d'énergie qu'il n'en consomment
extraordinaire donc vous avez vous
arrivez dans ces bâtiments la facture
des gens c'est 3 euros 4 euros par mois
parce que le bâtiment produit autant
d'énergie qu'il en consomme alors ça
veut dire des panneaux solaires sur le
toit quand c'est possible ça veut dire
la récupération de la chaleur ça veut
dire des performances énergétiques
exceptionnelles et surtout des
récupérations de chaleur le long des
circuits on maîtrise les technologies
donc ça ça pourrait être répandu c'est à
dire quand vous allez dans la salle de
chaudière la récupération de chaleur
elle est pas perdue elle est récupérée
et il y a même des effectivement on
récupère la chaleur dans les cuisines
quand vous faites votre cuisine il y a
de la chaleur cette chaleur est
récupérée et recycler pour qu'il n'y ait
zéro perdition de chaleur donc c'est
aussi des technologies à développer et
qui sont maîtrisés et surtout
l'isolation des toitures des portes des
fenêtres
et des façades c'est des technologies
qu'on maîtrise et donc il est
parfaitement possible de construire des
bâtiments à énergie positives
aujourd'hui ensuite j'avais mis
l'obligation de d'isolation quand il y a
des travaux de ravalement
la levée de bouclier que ça avait fait
et l'argument qu'utilisait à ce
moment-là ce qui résistait c'était non
mais quand il y a en Alsace quand il y a
des des
façades pardon
moi je suis non j'étais en Normandie
aussi donc il y avait quand il y a des
de ou du bois etc comme on va faire il
peut y avoir des exceptions on va pas
annuler un plan national et pour qui on
peut faire des exceptions effectivement
il y a les bateaux des bâtiments classés
on va pas coller des
de l'isolation extérieure sur les
bâtiments classés etc mais je me
souviens de ça parce que ça avait été
utilisé par les filières bâtiments pour
dire non mais faut pas c'est trop tôt
c'est trop vite etc sinon ce qui coûte
cher c'est les échafaudages et je vois
que ça a pas été rétabli ces
échafaudages donc autant en profiter et
plus on en fera moi ça coûtera cher
parce que plus on mettra au point des
matériaux intéressants sur y compris des
matériaux venant de l'agriculture
puisque l'agriculture française a des
tout premier potentiels en matière de
production de biomasse y compris de
matériaux d'isolation comme le chanvre
par exemple j'avais développé aussi une
chambre dans ma région parce que c'est
un des un des matériaux les plus
isolants en termes de d'efficacité
énergétique donc ça je trouve que
c'était très important il faudrait
vraiment remettre ça bon malheureusement
depuis le coup des travaux a augmenté
vous voyez donc ça veut bien dire qu'on
avait raison en 2015 à poser ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte plus cher de
faire des ravalement donc les gens
encore moins les moyens de faire les
deux c'est ça qui est dommage ensuite
les compteurs individuels de frais de
chauffage quelle bataille ça a été et
j'avais vu dans plusieurs rapports
parlementaires notamment dans les pays
voisins que quand vous avez un logement
collectif le jour où vous mettez des
calculs individuels de frais de
chauffage je vous jure que c'est vrai la
consommation diminue de 70%
parce que pourquoi parce que les gens
qui sortent de chez eux ils feront le
radiateur
ils partent en vacances il ferme le
radiateur et
quand c'est collectifs s'il voit pas
l'impact sur leur facture bon il ferme
pas le radiateur je ne vois pas pourquoi
il y a des conduire individuels pour
l'eau et pas des compteurs individuels
de frais de chauffage cette obligation a
été supprimée parce que aussi il y a eu
la pression des syndics de gestion c'est
à dire l'économise économiser l'énergie
c'est du voilà c'est c'est des
prestations en moins c'est c'est des
cirques économiques qui qui changent et
pourtant c'est extrêmement efficace
que de calculer individuellement les
frais de chauffage et c'est beaucoup
plus juste alors pour être exact aussi
il y a une grande et une grande
résistance des offices HLM
alors ça aussi ça me scandalisé je dis
mais vous devriez être les premiers à
réclamer l'individualisation des frais
de chauffage parce que ça va diminuer
collectivement la facture des gens alors
l'autre gros argument qui était c'était
dire oui mais ceux qui sont au
rez-de-chaussée et ceux qui sont en
dernière étape vont avoir plus de
chauffage que ceux qui sont dans le
sandwich au milieu de là où c'est
chauffé au-dessus c'est pas grave on
fait une paire équation que on peut très
bien
Périco et pour 10% de la facture pour
tenir compte de cette configuration et
puis après ceux qui sont en haut ils ont
une plus belle vue aussi enfin je veux
dire on s'arrête par mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a ce petit point là qui fait que
dans le collectif en tout cas il n'y a
pas de problème sans solution je pense
que ce problème là il peut être
également résolu
ensuite il y a eu un bonus de
constructibilité pour les constructions
exemplaires du point de vue énergétique
et environnemental alors ça je sais pas
si ça a été maintenu en tout cas c'est
très efficace parce que par exemple pour
les immeubles en bois
construction bois comme l'épaisseur est
plus importantes les promoteurs nous
disaient les constructeurs nous disaient
mais non vous allez nous faire perdre en
mètre carré habitable
puisque si on fait de l'isolation les
murs sont plus épais les planchers sont
plus épais donc on va perdre en hauteur
sous plafond etc et à ce moment j'avais
dit ceux qui sont haute performance
environnementale et notamment les
constructions bois parce que là aussi il
perdait un demi étage dans une
construction bois vous aurez un bonus de
mètres carrés et de constructibilité
pour tenir compte de la contrainte voilà
du différentiel donc ça c'était aussi
important de reconnaître cette
préoccupation là
ensuite il y a eu le soutien aux
particuliers donc pour financer la
rénovation énergétique de leur logement
avec
la réforme de l'écho-préatoséro le
crédit d'impôt de transition énergétique
et la possibilité de cumuler les deux
avant c'était pas cumulable moi j'ai
autorisé le cumul des deux aujourd'hui
il y a la prime rénove mais je sais pas
si vous avez curiosité de regarder les
dossiers
la primorenave c'est un dossier de 10
pages le mon crédit d'impôt il y avait
trois cases à cocher dans votre
déclaration d'impôts
et donc j'avais simplifié la procédure
parce que c'est vrai que le ministère
des Finances ils ont beaucoup de parents
pour inventer des déductions fiscales
inapplicables c'était très très
compliqué il y avait très peu de
bénéficiaires du dispositif antérieur
parce que il fallait faire plus
obligatoirement plusieurs travaux vous
étiez obligés d'isoler par exemple les
combles et les fenêtres
mais vous pouviez pas avoir le crédit
d'impôt si vous n'isoliez par exemple
que vos fenêtres et à ce moment-là
j'avais dit mais les gens ils sont
parfois forcément les moyens de faire
tout tout de suite donc il faut laisser
faire les travaux voyez sur deux ans ou
sur trois ans pour pouvoir étaler le
coût des travaux et les investissements
nécessaires
et donc c'était très très simple crédit
d'impôt bien vous faisiez les travaux
que vous vouliez vous avez votre
déduction fiscale et j'étais
extraordinaire et donc dans la foulée
pour que les gens se fassent pas rouler
quand même par des mauvais artisans on
avait créé le
comment dirais-je le conventionnement
certains artisans devaient prouver leur
compétences et les prix qui pratiquaient
pour éviter vous voyez l'effet de
cliquer c'est-à-dire vous donner un
crédit d'impôt pouf les prix augmentent
puis leur disant vous dire bah non vous
allez avoir le crédit d'impôt donc je
peux augmenter les prix donc on a vu
surveiller tous tous protocole et
surtout on avait
lycé la liste des artisans qui étaient
homologués pour faire les travaux
d'économie d'énergie
le jour où le crédit d'impôt a été
supprimé mais c'était dramatique c'est à
dire que les artisans étaient un effort
pour se former pour former leur salarié
pour recruter ce que ça avait les
chantiers avait explosé dans le domaine
notamment à l'isolation des fenêtres
et des portes et d'isolation des des
combles c'était les trois sujets qui
entraînaient les économies d'énergie
alors l'isolation des murs c'était un
peu plus cher mais je pense que les gens
si c'était ça avait été maintenu vous
voyez les gens l'auraient fait des
années suivantes en fait l'isolation par
l'extérieur ou par l'intérieur quand il
y avait des boiseries
voilà et donc ça s'est arrêté et je
pense que dans le secteur je sais pas
peut-être eu 10 000 emplois qui ont dû
être supprimés dans le secteur des
isolation des fenêtres enfin c'est voilà
ça a été des une d'isolation et je pense
ça c'est une réflexion globale il faut
de la continuer dans ces domaines pour
les entreprises pour ça c'est
insupportable ça bouge tout le temps les
dossiers bougent les noms des dossiers
bougent il faut du temps vous voyez pour
une entreprise donc là ils ont eu
2016-2017 2018 ça c'est effondré et
alors que je pense qu'on aurait continué
les thèmes CV et le crédit d'impôt
mais je pense qu'on aurait peut-être
aujourd'hui 50% des bâtiments isolés
d'abord tous les bâtiments publics ont
été faits parce que tous les maires
faisaient leurs écoles leur mairie les
salles polyvalentes
les départements faisaient les les
collèges je pense que tout ça aurait été
fait avec le
l'étape CV donc j'avais 1750 millions
d'euros il va y avoir à nouveau 750
millions normalement il devait y avoir
un milliard et demi il y a eu 750
millions d'euros qui ont été distribués
au collectivités locales et ça devait
continuer les années suivantes et puis
ça aussi
ça s'est arrêté et comme moi j'avais
l'expérience en tant qu'élud local de
région des complexités des subventions
d'État j'avais archi mais simplifié à
tel point qu'il y a eu un rapport de la
Cour des comptes dans un premier acné
parce que j'avais fait des argumentaires
mais la tracasserie vous connaissez ça
d'aller chercher les cofinancements
alors l'état de 10% enfin vous pouvez
vous conseille générale au conseil
régional à la Caisse des Dépôts je lui
ai dit non sur la loi de transition
énergétique il faut que ça aille vite et
on fait en fait en financer à 100% les
opérations dans les territoires énergies
positifs donc il y a une belle
opérations qui qui se sont développées
et ça aussi ça aurait dû être
poursuivi après la mise en place de
sociétés de tiers financement je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de ça c'était
original c'était une dérogation monopole
bancaire pour avancer aux particuliers
qui engage les travaux de rénovation
énergétique
un ces sociétés de tiers financement et
la Banque européenne d'investissement
j'étais allé voir pour financer cette
opération avait financé auteur de 400
millions d'euros et c'est une idée qui
m'avait été donnée par des collectivités
locales ça parce que les départements en
particulier qui avaient du mal aussi à
emprunter même si la Caisse des Dépôts
faisait des prêts c'est sur le terrain
que j'avais eu trouvé cette idée de
société de tiers financement et ça
c'était formidable parce que du coup il
y avait il y avait le prix des travaux
mais il y avait pas en plus vous voyez
le prix de l'emprunt pour les gens et je
les collectivités locales aussi ont pu y
accéder
le point suivant c'est des appels à
projet pour des réalisations
urbaines innovantes et exemplaires donc
on avait mis en place j'ai mis en place
16 démonstrateurs industriels pour la
ville durable qui avait été désigné le
23 décembre 2015 donc en application la
loi transition énergétique ça m'a vu le
permis de valoriser ça à la COP 21 et
c'est démonstrateurs donc il y avait 16
démonstrateurs industriels qui étaient
remontées avec un appel à projet et des
opérations donc urbaine que qui du coup
pouvait obtenir des financements
complémentaires
voilà après il y a le problème des
transports mais bon c'est d'autres
sujets mais voilà l'essentiel mais
d'ailleurs que vous avez parfaitement
pardon j'étais peut-être un peu longue
résumé tout à l'heure merci madame la
ministre je vais y laisser la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
madame la ministre déjà pour cette cet
état des lieux en tout cas sur sur ce
qui a pu ce que vous avez pu mettre en
mettre en œuvre et notamment à travers
le texte sur la transition énergétique
pour la pour la croissance verte c'est
vrai que vous avez fait un état de lieux
assez assez précis et c'est vrai que ce
texte déjà en 2015 on se laisse fixer
des objectifs assez ambitieux même très
ambitieux sur 500 000 logements 500 000
logements rénovés la suppression des
passoires thermiques et c'est vrai qu'on
est pour le coup aujourd'hui loin loin
du compte donc je voulais déjà savoir si
selon vous qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a
péché quoi alors vous avez vous en avez
un petit peu un petit peu dit mais
est-ce que c'est justement la
suppression de certaines mesures dont
vous avez évoqué est-ce que c'est un
manque de financement et notamment c'est
vrai que ça m'intéresserait de savoir à
la fois vous en tant que mini sur les
arbitrages en termes de financement
est-ce que
est importante mais du coup est-ce que
ça aurait permis d'aller beaucoup plus
vite enfin voilà et d'avoir un petit peu
votre votre vision par rapport à au fait
que justement on n'a pas atteint nos
objectifs qu'on en est encore encore
assez loin j'avais une question aussi
peut-être sur la question que vous avez
beaucoup appuyé sur la question des
territoires et de l'aspect local et
c'est vrai que moi je trouve qui avait
été intéressant qui avait été mis en
place vous en avez parlé à travers tes
post-type CV territoire énergie positive
et le fait que effectivement il y ait
des financements local qui soit mise en
place et notamment à travers cette
période la mise en place de de
plateformes de rénovation thermique qui
ont et qui ont été mis en place sur les
sur les territoires et c'est vrai que de
mon regard en tout cas des lieux local
ce que j'ai pu voir c'est que ces
plateformes quand elles étaient en place
et notamment sur des secteurs plutôt
plutôt rural mais on a les Alecs sur des
sur des zones beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus denses étaient quand même un
système qui fonctionne
qui fonctionne toujours d'ailleurs mais
qui fonctionne plutôt bien avec
notamment avec proximité un
accompagnement c'est vrai collègue
François de Rugy tout à l'heure était
moins enthousiaste sur cette question là
puisque l'exemple qui donnait en disant
que oui ça a fonctionné mais c'est très
petit à une échelle sauf que l'exemple
qu'il a donné sans logement pour 50 000
pour un territoire de 50 000 habitants
mine de rien si on le rapporte à la à
l'échelle du pays c'est pas si mal faire
en tout cas les a pas atteints en termes
de rénovation globale et de Bâtiment
Basse Consommation donc je trouvais en
tout cas que c'est un dispositif qui
était intéressant et dont je voulais
avoir votre votre avis et sur peut-être
la poursuite de ça et sur le fait que on
s'aperçoit que ces plateformes de
rénovation sont en souvent en difficulté
sur les territoires par manque de
financement d'accompagnement etc
donc voilà si vous pouviez peut-être
nous dire quelques mots là-dessus et
puis sur l'évolution donc vous avez
parlé du cice et l'évolution vers ma
prime ma prime rénove
voilà voir la vidéo aussi également
esquisser mais un petit peu votre votre
avis sur sur cet aspect sur cet aspect
là j'ai compris l'intérêt effectivement
du crédit du crédit d'impôt
qu'avait quand même quelques
problématiques aussi par rapport à il y
a eu quand même pas mal de sujets à la
fois de fraude des phénomènes enfin en
tout cas il y a eu quand même quelques
quelques
problématiques par rapport à au cite
mais bon prime rénov on s'aperçoit qu'on
a un peu un peu également les mêmes
dérives donc à voir aussi votre avis
là-dessus et puis peut-être terminé
aussi parce que vous en avez aussi un
petit peu parlé peut-être sur les
exemples à l'étranger
si justement quand vous avez travaillé
sur la question est-ce que vous étiez à
la fois inspiré est-ce que vous avez des
exemples à l'étranger qui pourraient
justement en termes de d'efficacité en
terme de politique publique qui ont été
mis en place voilà merci
micro s'il vous plaît
voilà merci monsieur le rapporteur tout
d'abord merci de d'évoquer effectivement
les plateformes de rénovation qui ont
été mises en place avec des partenariats
très intéressants et là aussi très libre
en fonction des collectivités
territoriales et notamment partenaire en
lien avec la dame donc ce qui était très
ce qui était très intéressant dans ces
plateformes d'ailleurs tous les
territoires énergies positifs mettez en
place des plateformes c'est-à-dire que
les gens ils sont un peu perdus quand
ils se disent il faut faire des travaux
à qui on s'adresse comment ça se passe
et l'intérêt des plateformes c'est que
elles avaient je pense que c'est
toujours le cas d'ailleurs
une bande de données c'est par exemple
vous voulez mettre une chaudière bois
dans un immeuble collectif j'avais fait
en sorte qu'ils aient des crédits pour
mettre en place des plaques des des
banques de données vous tapez chauffage
bois et vous avez les réalisations qui
ont été homologuées etc et donc vous
pouvez aller visiter des réalisations
que vous voulez réaliser dans votre
commune dans votre canton dans votre
territoire et ça c'est irremplaçable
parce que
je veux dire territoire par territoire
il y a pas forcément la ressource
industrielle ou artisanale et en
revanche dès que vous allez voir des
choses faites beaucoup d'ailleurs par
exemple de l'agriculteurs ce sont des
placés sur les méthaniseurs parce qu'ils
avaient envie d'aller voir là où ça
marchait est-ce que ça correspondait à
leur potentiel et cetera et c'est vrai
aussi donc pour les bâtiments et les et
les opérations d'innovation
d'isolation thermique des bâtiments donc
ça je crois que c'est effectivement très
important
votre deuxième question c'est sur les 2e
question c'est sur oui qu'est-ce qu'il y
a raté c'est l'arrêt
c'est tellement difficile vous savez
dans des arbitrages interministériels
c'était des combats d'obtenir un crédit
d'impôt je sais pas si vous rendez
compte par rapport au ministère des
Finances c'est mamie inimaginable
d'obtenir un crédit d'impôt moi comment
je faisais jiminer comme 21 comme 21
comme 21 il faut qu'on soit à la hauteur
de la COP 21 il faut faire des choses
extra exceptionnelles parce que c'est la
cop21 c'est comme ça que j'arrive à
arracher les arbitrages mais c'était pas
c'était pas évident donc voir ensuite
au-delà des clivages politiques
d'ailleurs que ça s'arrête c'est
désolant parce que vous disiez c'est
tellement difficile le temps que les
gens se l'approprient que ça soit connu
qu'on envoie les instructions que les
artisans et les entreprises du bâtiment
s'y habitue que les gens parce qu'il y a
des gens aussi beaucoup de gens qui
avaient programmé des travaux puis paf
ça s'est arrêté du jour au lendemain
donc c'est il y a eu un potentiel de
développement économique même qui a été
qui a été perdue et sur l'étape CV donc
c'est pareil c'est merveilleux quand
vous regardez les thèmes CV il y a
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours les inventaire
de tout ce qui a été fait
c'est un peu continué mais brutalement
il y avait ce soutien financier et
c'était formidable parce que on voyait
tous les mers les prisons de communauté
de communes venir au ministère ont
projeté ce qu'ils avaient réalisé sur
leur territoire mais c'était merveilleux
Xavier la diversité française avec la
diversité des ressources locales des
mères et des élus qui connaissaient mais
rien à l'écologie et qui tout d'un coup
se passionner sur ces sujets puis après
il se passionné pour la biodiversité et
puis après il se passionnait sur les
expériences éducatives dans leurs écoles
c'est très très vertueux l'environnement
ça tire tout le monde vers le haut donc
c'est formidable et les gens apprenaient
ils réalisaient c'était c'est très très
gratifiant en plus pour les élus et moi
j'apportais l'argent
en ayant essayé normalement on m'avait
promis un milliard et demi
je vais calculer ça j'ai eu un an il y a
un milliard et demi il y a du potentiel
etc donc la première enveloppe ça a été
750 millions et quand je suis parti
devait y avoir 750 millions et c'est et
ça n'a pas été reprise a été supprimé
enfin ça n'a pas été défendu ça n'a pas
été supprimé donc il y a beaucoup de
collectivités qui avaient des projets
qui n'ont pas pu être réalisés
donc ça c'est voilà je pense que plus
c'est simple c'est efficace plus les
gens s'en saisissent et il faut alors
par rapport à la question que vous posez
sur la fraude
c'est vrai que c'était quelque chose qui
était qui était objectif en terminant
les gens vont frauder et alors c'était
quoi l'idée c'était dire avec le crédit
d'impôt un énorme les gens vont faire
des travaux et de toute façon ils les
auraient fait même sans crédit d'impôt
oui mais alors où est le problème enfin
je veux dire ils font autre chose du
coup s'ils ont un peu plus d'argent bah
ils feront autre chose ça fera marcher
le bâtiment localement où est le
problème donc après c'était oui mais
alors il va y avoir des trucages parce
qu'en fait ils vont refaire leur
fenêtres ça va coûter un peu moins cher
et en fait il fera enfin de la pièce et
donc du coup ils feront payer la
repenture
écoutez moi alors j'entendais ça dans
les arbitrages interministériel j'ai
écouté moi on fait pas on met pas en
place d'action politique en s'occupant
des fraudeurs parce que sinon alors
comment est-ce qu'on avance sans comment
ça soupçonner tout le monde de frauder
et puis il vaut mieux une ou deux bonnes
sanctions sur un ou deux fraudeur et
tout le monde sera dissuadé notamment
les entreprises qui pouvaient
éventuellement et encore est-ce que ça
s'est fait je ne sais pas ce qui est en
tout cas vrai c'est que quand vous
faites refaire votre fenêtre vous faites
repeindre la pièce c'est à dire que
c'est un effet d'entraînement sur la
filière bâtiment c'est ça que je disais
c'est pas de la fraude ils font pas
payer ça de toute façon ils dépensent
plus en rembourser pas 100% et c'est
parce que c'était 9000 euros mais dans
une limite donc on ne remboursait jamais
100%, il fallait dépenser beaucoup plus
que plus que 8000 euros je sais plus
combien c'était 50% 30% je me souviens
plus quel était le pourcentage donc si
vous voulez avec
avec un milliard et demi de crédit
d'impôts de déduction fiscale ça fait à
peu près un milliard et demi on a généré
moi je pense qu'on a généré 10 fois plus
de travaux on a généré 8 à 10 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires dans les
industries du bâtiment parce que vous
refaites refaire les fenêtres
après vous faites d'isolation des
combles vous voyez après vous changez
votre chaudière enfin il y a de la
cohérence c'est un effet d'entraînement
donc je disais au ministère des finances
mais non le crédit d'impôts ça coûte un
milliard et demi mais non ça coûte pas
un milliard et demi ça rapporte puisque
sur les 10 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires les gens vont il y a des
impôts qui vont être payés des
cotisations sociales qui ont été payées
il y a des retours sur investissement
qui vont être payés donc non vous
injectez vous investissez un milliard et
demi
30%. donc vous voyez 30% ça veut dire
que si vous vouliez être remboursé de
8000 euros il fallait dépenser 24000
euros en travaux sinon vous aviez moins
par exemple vous voyez être en beaucoup
vous pouvez faire 8000 euros de travaux
vous aviez un tiers de remboursement
c'était raisonnable c'était pas 100%.
mais du coup ça a incité les gens à
faire plus de travaux qu'il n'aurait
fait et surtout parmi ces travaux à
faire les travaux d'isolation en premier
c'est ça qui est intéressant parce que
si vous voulez l'améliorer votre
intérieur vous dites bon j'ai pas les
moyens d'isoler les fenêtres je vais
quand même un bon coup de peinture je
vais acheter des meubles sympas je vais
d'abord penser à ma qualité de vie alors
que si on vous dit ben non si vous
faites en plus isolation des fenêtres
vous êtes remboursés vous faites
isolation des fenêtres donc vous
économisez l'énergie donc vous
économisez du CO2 donc vous participez
aussi à la protection de la planète donc
c'était un cercle vertueux en fait
alors y a-t-il des questions de la part
de nos collègues oui Laurent Burgoa oui
merci Madame la présente merci
madame la ministre pour vous expliquer
par rapport justement au crédit d'impôts
à vous poser un ministre si vous revenez
à des responsabilités est-ce que vous
remettiez le crédit d'impôt lorsque vous
proposerai autre chose qu'on mesure en
matière de politique dans ce domaine là
bien sûr je remets le crédit d'impôt
bien
encore tellement de choses à faire
crédit d'impôts et les territoires
énergies positives c'est tellement
efficace et vous donner un maire les
moyens de d'isoler son école mais il le
fait tout de suite et en plus c'est
entretient le tissu de d'artisans du
territoire vous voyez c'est c'est
extraordinaire
c'est tout simple bien sûr j'en mets le
crédit d'impôt l'isolation obligatoire
le
calcul individuel des frais de chauffage
mais c'est tellement efficace
c'est tellement efficace quand vous
regardez votre facteur de dos vous
faites attention vous dites tiens
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand ça dépasse
si vous n'avez même pas le compteur de
votre chauffage
si vous vous rendez pas compte de
l'effort que vous faites alors
maintenant on le fait parce que les
enfin moi j'ai toujours fait donc
se moquer de moi parce que je sortais de
mon bureau de ministre j'étais ni la
lumière alors on dit mais c'était mieux
mais dans la lumière moi j'étais à la
lumière j'ai été éduqué comme ça
j'éteins la lumière donc je donnais des
instructions chacun éteint la lumière en
sortant du bureau alors irrit et Souka
mais je sais après ils ont pris
l'habitude j'ai dit maintenant c'est
quand même les contribua qui payent
l'énergie vous sortez votre bureau vous
éteignez la lumière
le Président Madame le Ministre avec les
exemples que vous avez cité je pense que
effectivement vous avez dit que vous
aviez reçu des élus des territoires des
maires qui avaient gagné en compétence
en matière écologique et je pense que
l'impact l'effet levier que vous
évoquiez sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs dont vous étiez à l'origine
aujourd'hui on le retrouve à différents
niveaux de collectivité le plaisir et
l'honneur de présider un département
avec 125 collèges par exemple cette
conscience aujourd'hui en matière de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
elle est acquise
alors on continue à faire des collèges
neufs fort heureusement pour pour le
bâtiment mais on a aussi une expertise
sur ceux qui peuvent encore voir leur
durée de de prolonger et améliorer leur
performances énergétique je vous rejoins
aussi sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons nous avons un voire deux
téléphones très
très lourd en capacité et notamment en
logiciel qui sont téléchargeables et
aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de
télécharger un certain nombre
d'applications c'est le mot que je
cherchais d'application pour le suivi de
nos consommations et donc je pense que
tout cela va peut-être aussi aider nos
concitoyens à avoir une meilleure
gestion de de ces choses là il y a un
sujet qui n'a pas été abordé et moi
j'avais eu l'occasion dans le cadre d'un
programme d'échange européen de suivre
ça c'est sur la géothermie à partir des
eaux d'exorent et il se trouve que nous
avons plusieurs territoires miniers en
France que ce soit dans ou dans le
département du Nord et du Pas-de-Calais
et j'avais vu en Hollande alors le
modèle économique était un peu faussé
parce que c'était expérimental et il
savait bénéficier de crédits européens
assez conséquent mais la géothermie à
partir des eaux d'exorent marche
notamment sur les équipements publics
sur le logement collectif etc et
pourquoi il y a un frein chez nous à
aller vers la géothermie est-ce que vous
avez une idée par rapport à ça c'est une
énergie que j'ai que j'aime beaucoup la
géothermie elle résolu c'est un peu
comme l'hydroélectricité ces énergies
qui ont résolu le problème de stockage
c'est formidable j'ai ouvert une usine
de géothermie quand j'étais ministre en
Guadeloupe qui était à l'arrêt puis
personne n'y croyait je pense qu'on a
perdu peut-être un des savoir-faire des
ingénieurs qui se sont peut-être un peu
détournés de cette énergie mais c'est
formidable la géothermie et d'ailleurs à
la COP 21 on a créé une coalition
géothermie alors
un groupe de recherche scientifiques et
il y a des pays qui
ignoraient complètement qu'ils avaient
ce potentiel sous leurs pieds et qui
aujourd'hui sont équipés en géothermie
et donc vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est pas une énergie qui est considérée
comme en haut du haut de la pile si
j'ose dire mais partout il y a de la
géothermie il faut absolument développer
ça ça c'est évident
Laurent saumon
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre j'ai bien compris effectivement
vous êtes plutôt pour une rénovation qui
soit qui puisse être en tout cas
parcellaire et pas forcément globale
pour pouvoir bénéficier de ces aides
j'ai compris aussi que il y avait une
importance et je la partage cette
continuité des politiques en matière de
logement pour avoir effectivement une
réussite et pouvoir constater des
résultats vous avez dit qu'il fallait
que ce soit simple qu'il fallait
effectivement remettre l'avoir fiscale
n'est pas parlé tellement de
l'organisation aujourd'hui on voit avec
habiter mieux et la gestion faite par
Lana qui a beaucoup de retard dans les
financements et qui j'allais dire sinon
des gouttes ou en tout cas fait ralentir
peut-être les possibilités qu'on a
qu'est-ce que vous pensez justement de
du rôle de Lana en tout cas tel qu'il
est géré aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
ces rénovations thermiques
indispensables pour améliorer le
développement durable et la protection
des bourses des habitants et également
du climat
[Musique]
moyens n'avaient pas non plus les moyens
de faire ne relever à la fois pas de la
NA mais en même temps n'avait pas les
moyens de faire leur travaux parce qu'il
y avait la disparition du crédit d'impôt
ils se sont tournés vers Lana voyez
alors qu'avant l'ANA fonctionnait bien
parce que ceux qui n'avaient pas les
moyens ils savaient que c'était pour eux
et les autres ce qui pouvaient un peu
payer et qui avaient crédit d'impôt ils
insistaient pas pour dire on veut
absolument les l'argent de la nappe
puisqu'on leur dit ben non vous avez le
crédit d'impôt donc essayez d'utiliser
le crédit d'impôt je le répète avec une
ristourne parce que c'est un crédit
d'impôts si vous payez pas d'impôts vous
avez l'équivalent de votre 30% de ce que
vous avez dépensé et donc c'est pour ça
je pense que que la NAR a rencontré
ensuite des difficultés plus j'imagine
des dotations de budgétaire de
fonctionnement
donc il faudrait recentrer la nage je
pense sur les plus défavorisés les plus
modestes et remettre un crédit d'impôts
en contrôlant bien sûr les prix de des
travaux remettez un crédit d'impôt pour
les catégories moyennes et autres alors
après il y a le
il y a les conditions de ressources
c'est un vrai débat ça moi j'avais
refusé les conditions de ressources
parce que je dis le temps perdu la
question du reste à charge peut-être
aussi et la question du reste à charge
donc sur les conditions de ressources
j'avais pas mis de conditions de
ressources parce que j'avais dit ce
qu'il faut c'est développé
les travaux que les gens qui peuvent
payer ils vont avoir leur crédit d'impôt
mais c'est le rôle de la fiscalité
d'être juste et ça fait moins de
contrôle parce que comment ça a
contrôler qui gagne pas les évolutions
perdez des mois à contrôler le contrôle
et le les seuils d'impôts ça crée des
effets de seuil et l'idée que je veux
que j'avais à laquelle j'avais pensé
c'est dire plus il va y avoir de travaux
plus les artisans les entreprises du
bâtiment pourront se développer sur ces
technologies de performance énergétique
des bâtiments et donc en retour tout le
monde en profitera parce que ça fera une
baisse des prix etc alors que si vous
limitez si vous mettez des conditions de
ressources très basses vous n'avez pas
un marché suffisamment ambitieux pour
que les entreprises investissent vous
voyez et donc la masse la première année
de la commande sur les travaux puisque
c'est quand même de la redmi rien qu'en
rembourser uniquement le remboursement
donc la totalité des travaux comme j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure faisait beaucoup
plus ça crée un marché solvable donc les
entreprises elles peuvent investir elles
peuvent former des gens elles peuvent
correctement les payer elles peuvent
faire attention aux matériaux qu'elles
utilisent etc et puis peut-être qu'après
dans deux trois ans après on aurait pu
mettre une condition de ressources mais
une fois que les choses se seraient
voyez bien installés
et que ceux qui ont le plus d'argent qui
auraient déjà fait leurs travaux à ce
moment-là ils arrivent à un seuil et du
coup on aurait pu concentrer les
investissements sur les autres
catégories mais pas tout de suite parce
qu'il fallait créer un marché
c'était ça le raisonnement
je le rapporteur
c'était pour rebondir sur ce que vous
disiez sur effectivement sur la question
du reste à charge
qui est pas qui est pas de conditions de
ressources je enfin je l'entends mais ce
qu'on s'aperçoit aussi c'est que sur les
les foyers les plus précaires en fait
le reste à charge c'est ce qui bloque
justement parce que quand même si on a
un crédit d'impôts maintenant ma prime
rénov etc il reste quand même et même si
c'est un crédit taux zéro etc il reste
quand même quelque chose et souvent qui
est bloquant pour les personnes avec les
plus faibles revenus quoi et donc du
coup la question justement du reste à
charge zéro il se pose quand même là du
coup pour les plus les plus bas revenus
donc je sais pas si c'est quelque chose
sur lequel vous aviez pu
réfléchir ouais c'est l'intervention
c'est Lana qui peut prendre le reste à
charge dès lors que les autres ont un
crédit d'impôt vous concentrez le rôle
de l'agence nationale l'amélioration de
l'habitat sur la prise en charge du
reste à charge et même sur l'avance des
fonds des travaux
par ailleurs c'est les propriétaires
donc si vous êtes modeste et que vous
êtes propriétaire déjà vous êtes
propriétaire la intervient donc à
intervient directement pour vous si vous
êtes propriétaire et que vous louez à
quelqu'un de modeste c'est plus souvent
ça et qu'en plus vous louez une passoire
thermique Lana l'intervient mais elle
valorise le bien du propriétaire qui est
pas forcément lui dans une situation
modeste vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc le nombre de gens très modernes qui
en plus sont propriétaires et qui n'ont
pas les moyens de faire les travaux
c'est quand même relativement restreint
et donc cela vous avez raison la nappe
peut prendre en charge la totalité des
travaux
merci
un présidente madame la ministre moi je
me demandais que pensez-vous de
l'installation sur les toits plats
de panneaux solaires notamment pour tout
ce qui est les logements HLM souvent on
a des
logements en tout cas dans le sud
puisque comme vous le voyez avec mon
accent
voilà et est-ce que vous avez une idée
de la production que cela pourrait
représenter au total en France dans
l'atteinte de notre autonomie
énergétique est-ce qu'il y a eu un
calcul est-ce que ça a été étudié ça
c'est tous les trois étaient équipés
et équipés
là on produit à peu près en énergie
renouvelable l'é de 6 réacteurs
nucléaires depuis la montée en puissance
de tout compris sauf l'hydroélectricité
l'éolien etc donc je pense que c'est
quand même un ou deux réacteurs
nucléaires faciles l'équipement en
énergie après vous avez deux de
mécanismes soit en autoconsommation vous
mettez vos panneaux vous éclairez etc
nous te consommation soit vous renvoyer
vers le réseau et à ce moment-là vous
êtes remboursé de ce que vous revendez
sur le réseau c'est souvent comme ça que
font les les bâtiments collectifs
puisque du coup ça diminue aussi les
charges énergétiques de l'ensemble des
habitants de l'immeuble mais vous avez
raison
et non seulement si ça ça avait c'est
pour ça que quand j'ai dit quand je
disais on va rendre tous les bâtis tous
les nouveaux bâtiments obligatoires
énergies positive alors ça faisait une
révolution ça faisait un saut
technologique moi je pense que dans un
certain moment d'histoire oui il faut
faire un saut technologique comme quand
on est passé du téléphone à au portable
il y a bien eu un saut technologique
donc dans l'énergie il y a un saut il y
a un saut technologique une révolution à
faire pour dire bah oui d'accord allez à
partir de la semaine prochaine tous les
permis devront être énergies positif un
moment faut bien faut bien se lancer
est-ce que vous disiez très juste on
dirait ben écoutez tous les trois qui
peuvent être équipés en énergie solaire
dans les régions ensoleillées allez il
faut tous le faire mais vous savez on
pourrait commencer par les aéroports
combien de fois j'ai parlé au président
de l'aéroport de Paris j'ai fait des
centrales solaires sur vos toits toutes
les grandes surfaces tous les carrefours
tout ça ça devrait être obligatoire
centrales solaires surtout les toits
partout et la récupération d'eau de
pluie partout
[Musique]